[Musik]
ein nicht unwahrscheinliches bauwerk ein
kühnes versprechen von anfang an die
sehnsucht einer stadt die nach einem
symbol dürfte jetzt thront es immer eine
der kostbarsten gebäude der welt alles
beginnt mit einem alten café
speicherhaus und einer skizze die der
architekt jacques herzog zeichnet für
einen studienkollegen
wer hat einen traum von einem
konzertsaal in luftiger höhe mit
irgendeinem konzertsaal eine der besten
der welt soll hamburg bekommt ein
investor soll das meiste finanzieren
mit der vermarktung von luxuswohnungen
und einem hotel spenden fließen
reichlich die stadt bekommt ihr
wahrzeichen was macht
zwei jahre werben die initianten für
ihre vision und löwen in der stadt
cancún erwartet eine welle der euphorie
aus ich spüre eine gewisse spannung aber
nicht nur in karlsruhe auch bei jungen
das projekt wird tatsächlich aufgegleist
und nach nur zweieinhalb jahren planung
beschließt das hamburger parlament den
bau einstimmen
der grundstein gelegt für 241 millionen
euro soll das einzigartige gebäude
errichtet werden und der freut den
bürgermeister wird ein magnet sein und
die menschen in der stadt in
norddeutschland ich bin sicher in ganz
europa vielleicht sogar der ganzen welt
begeistern animieren zu uns zu kommen
in basel haben die architekten von
herzog & de meuron zum ersten mal einen
konzertsaal einer der macher und gerade
das herzstück des kulturtempels der
große saal ist noch längst nicht fertig
geplant den hamburg überhastet mit dem
bau begonnen wird ohne so genau zu
wissen was man will und wer das bezahlen
soll entstehen auf einer baustelle die
im chaos versinkt
der boden kann das gewicht des gebäudes
nicht tragen und immer neue komplizierte
planänderungen kommen dazu der
kalkulierte preis lässt sich nicht
halten aber erfreulich diese
eröffnungstermin 2010 ist dann das jahr
das riecht da müssen helfer und dem raum
gute miene zum bösen spiel machen
[Musik]
das schwierigste projekt das sie jemals
hatten mieter bauskandal symbol des
größenwahns und es kommt noch schlimmer
als es streit um die statik des daches
gibt schieben sich die baufirma hochtief
und die architekten die schuld
gegenseitig zu baustopp über ein jahr
das wahrzeichen nimmt schaden und wird
immer teurer
für die stadt die wissen als bauherrin
die investoren abgelöst hat die
erwartungen an die architekten sind auch
nicht kleiner geworden
und die schweizer haben fünfte ansprüche
für die exquisite glasfassade betreiben
die juli-daten aufwand vielfach klar
wiedekings von verschiedenen herstellern
hatten wie gedruckt außen verchromen
waschen in einer eigens gebauten
maschine und schließlich in wellen
gestalt bieten 40 spezialisten in padua
vermögen noch einmal muss die stadt
drauflegen
fast 200 millionen nur so garantiert die
baufirma das hercules projekt zu ende zu
bringen
und allmählich 3 sparen der traut er
toyota der star akustiker aus japan kann
die dal austarieren und mit der
individuell gefrästen gipsplatten für
himmlischen klang von ende 2016 leipzig
der hamburger volk die auch das gebäude
ist tatsächlich fertig geworden
sechs jahre später als geplant
und nun fällt es selbst den kritischen
geistern schwer sich der fct dieses
ortes zu entziehen
ein wunder der erste überragende bau des
jahrtausends eine neue epoche so tönt es
nun aber ist es die exorbitanten kosten
wird die musiker jedenfalls liefen sich
rasch überzeugen
da viele kollegen hatten themen auf der
hase aber überwältigen mitgefühl sich zu
hören sich zu spüren auch diese wucht
und und diese transparenz zu erleben
dieser war ihm anbietet vielleicht
tröstet es die sache so zu betrachten
ein kulturtempel wie dieser ist eine
kathedrale unserer zeit und gegen kosten
und bauzeit von sauerland im dom steht
diese elbphilharmonie noch ganz
ordentlich darf